there's a lot of structured data out
there perhaps more than any other type
in it's ripe for use with machine
learning let's explore a new tool that
aims to automatically build and deploy
machine learning models on structured
data will it live up to the promise stay
tuned to find out
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we're going to try
out Auto ml tables one of the newest
Auto ml products that Google has added
Auto ml tables enables you to
automatically build and deploy
state-of-the-art machine learning models
on unstructured data faster than you
could by hand it automates modeling on a
wide range of data types from numbers
and classes to strings
timestamps lists and nested fields
what's interesting about Auto ml tables
is that you can do all of this without
any coding work you just take an
exported CSV file click a few buttons
wait a while and you get a very highly
tuned model on the other end the team
has worked hard to enable the tool to
work for a wide variety of different
data types and it really explorers that
vast space of possible models and hyper
parameters to try to optimize things on
your behalf let's see what using Auto ml
tables looks like the first step is to
import your training data at the import
tab give it a name select the source
either a table from bigquery or a file
on Google Cloud Storage we're going to
use an open data set that describes
marketing outcomes of a Portuguese bank
and we'll try to model whether a bank
deposit will happen this first step
takes a bit of time as the system
analyzes the columns of your data set
once it's complete you'll get to edit
the auto-generated schema and select the
column for predicting on here you can
also update the column type as well as
whether it is nullable or not
the third tab is called analyze this is
a pretty interesting view and I think it
will be useful for those with datasets
that have a lot of columns so you get a
nice overview of their data you can even
click on the different column names to
see some statistics about your columns
after analyzing the data we're ready to
do the training this is where auto ml
really shines because well all you have
to do is click train there are some
options that you can set including a
maximum budget of training hours this
enables you to experiment with your data
but if you want and limit that training
time before committing to a full longer
training run you'll notice that the
training time shown are somewhat on a
long side of things and that's because
it's not only doing model tuning but
also selecting what model to use in the
first place
so as a result there's a lot of things
happening during training but luckily
for us we don't have to do anything time
to just go get lunch or something I
guess and we're back now we're on to the
fifth tab of auto ml tables which is
evaluation if you've used some of the
other auto oil products before this will
look pretty familiar you can see how the
training did as well as metrics about
the models performance and finally in
tab number six we can deploy the model
to get predictions there's even an
editor in the browser that will make
requests to your endpoint so you don't
need to set up a local environment to
make these calls to try and test out
your endpoint notice also there's an
option at the top of the page to toggle
between online predictions via the REST
API and batch predictions which allow
you to upload a CSV file or point to a
bigquery table and get prediction
results on that entire file or table
considering the amount of time it takes
to use auto ml Tables enables you to
achieve a much higher level of model
performance than you could reach
manually so if you have some structured
data you're thinking of doing some
machine learning on use this as an
excuse to try out Auto ml tables to see
if it's useful for you by selecting from
state-of-the-art models and then
carefully tuning the models during train
Auto amount tables can potentially save
you a lot of work thanks for watching
this episode of cloud AII adventures and
if you enjoyed it hit that like button
and be sure to subscribe to get all the
latest episodes right when they come out
for now check out Auto mouth tables and
harness the insights and your structured
[Music]
[Music]